your favorite band is great at playing
music but not so great at being
organized
they keep misplacing their instruments
on tour and it's driving their manager
mad on the day of the big concert the
band wakes up to find themselves tied up
in a windowless soundproof practice room
their manager explains what's happening
outside there are 10 large boxes each
contains one of your instruments
but don't be fooled by the pictures
they've been randomly placed
i'm going to let you out one at a time
while you're outside you can look inside
any five boxes before security takes you
back to the tour bus
you can't touch the instruments or in
any way communicate what you find to the
others
no marking the boxes shouting nothing
if each one of you can find your own
instrument then you can play tonight
otherwise the label is dropping you
you have three minutes to think about it
before we start
the band is in despair after all each
musician only has a fifty percent chance
of finding their instrument by picking
five random boxes and the chances that
all ten will succeed are even lower just
one in one thousand twenty four but
suddenly the drummer comes up with a
valid strategy that has a better than
thirty five percent chance of working
can you figure out what it was
here's what the drummer said
everyone first open the box with the
picture of your instrument if your
instrument is inside you're done
otherwise look at whatever's in there
and then open the box with that picture
on it keep going that way until you find
your instrument the bandmates are
skeptical but amazingly enough they all
find what they need and a few hours
later they're playing to thousands of
adoring fans so why did the drummer's
strategy work
each musician follows a linked sequence
that starts with the box whose outside
matches their instrument and ends with
the box actually containing it
note that if they kept going that would
lead them back to the start so this is a
loop
for example if the boxes are arranged
like so the singer would open the first
box to find the drums go to the eighth
box to find the base and find her
microphone in the third box which would
point back to the first
this works much better than random
guessing because by starting with the
box with the picture of their instrument
each musician restricts their search to
the loop that contains their instrument
and there are decent odds about 35
that all of the loops will be of length
5 or less
how do we calculate those odds for the
sake of simplicity we'll demonstrate
with a simplified case
four instruments and no more than two
guesses allowed for each musician
let's start by finding the odds of
failure the chance that someone will
need to open three or four boxes before
they find their instrument there are six
distinct four box loops
one fun way to count them is to make a
square
put an instrument at each corner and
draw the diagonals
see how many unique loops you can find
and keep in mind that these two are
considered the same they just start at
different points
these two however are different
we can visualize the eight distinct
three box loops using triangles
you'll find four possible triangles
depending on which instrument you leave
out and two distinct paths on each
so of the 24 possible combinations of
boxes there are 14 that lead to failure
and 10 that result in success
that computational strategy works for
any even number of musicians but if you
want a shortcut it generalizes to a
handy equation
plug in 10 musicians and we get odds of
about 35
what if there were a thousand musicians
a million
as n increases the odds approach about
30 percent
not a guarantee but with a bit of
musician's luck it's far from hopeless
hi everybody if you liked this riddle
try solving these two
you